Peter Brown here with a GameSpot news  update today Sony announced a brand new  4k video player that may look like a new  version of the PlayStation 4 but  unfortunately it isn't the 4k Ultra HD  media player goes on sale this summer  and allows you to download stream and  store a range of 4k video content Sony  didn't announce a price nor exact  dimensions for the device so it's  unknown if a PlayStation 4 will sit  nicely on top  reminiscent of the Sony disk drive  add-on for the Super Nintendo Sony is  also releasing several new 4k TVs but  there is currently no 4k support for the  PlayStation 4 prior to the consoles  launch Sony said that it was considering  adding 4k output for still picture  display and movie playback but has not  released any further information what do  you think is 4k a new fad or is it here  to stay let us know in the comments  below